will there be a russian invasion of
ukraine is the threat real or is it just
geopolitical posturing if the threat is
real then putin is really taking his
sweet time isn't he if it's just
posturing then why does putin keep it up
still even after his ultimatums have
been rejected as you might have guessed
there is no one word answer to the
question all i can give you is a better
idea of the situation so let's get into
it first let's reiterate some points
i've made in a community post earlier
this is needed to make sure we are on
the same wavelength you know i can make
all the arguments i want but if someone
believes that nato was about to invade
russia or something then it's all for
nothing point number one nato is a
defensive alliance countries join nato
by popular vote when people use the term
nato expansion what they mean or what
they should mean is sovereign countries
voting to join number 2 nato will never
invade russia russia has the largest
nuclear arsenal on the planet if nato
invades russia the world ends nobody
wants that number 3 the russian elite
knows that nato will never invade russia
fear of nato expansion is just a cover
for the actual goal which is the
rebuilding of the former russian soviet
sphere of influence some people want to
treat russia like some scared and
confused animal without any agency of
its own lashing out against a perceived
threat however this is an exotic
misunderstanding of the situation number
four if russia feels threatened by
sovereign countries joining a defensive
alliance that's russia's problem imagine
an abusive ex-husband feeling insecure
about his ex-wife taking self-defense
courses after he assaulted her multiple
times following their divorce number
five if russia doesn't want nato to
expand they shouldn't have created a
puppet state inside moldavia in 1992
shouldn't have invaded georgia in 2008
shouldn't have annexed crimea in 2014
and shouldn't have maintained a low
intensity conflict in the donbass since
2014 number six it is possible to be
critical of both u.s and russian
imperialism at the same time in fact you
should be it is also possible to say
that both are bad and acknowledge that
the russian imperialism is worse after
all both powers engage in foreign
interventions but at least the us
doesn't annex neighboring countries or
threaten them militarily us imperialism
tends to happen through soft power i.e
capitalism economic pressure and so on
while russian imperialism is more
scorched earth i.e rolling in the tanks
immediately after their country tries to
drift away from their sphere of
influence see hungary in 1956
czechoslovakia in 1968 ukraine in 2014
and so on number seven for all the
tankies out there supporting
geopolitical enemies of the us will not
help bring about a leftist utopia as bad
as the u.s is in many regards its
geopolitical enemies are far worse
russia is an oligarchic autocracy that
rigs elections and jails political
opponents while china is a surveillance
state tech dystopia since there is no
third position we choose the lesser of
two evils because above 80 iq we do
politics based on rationality not raw
emotions and no the u.s wanting to jail
snowden is not the same as russia
jailing galaxia navalny and then point
number eight is mostly about hasan abi
who really should stay away from this
subject because so far him offering any
commentary on the ukraine crisis did
nothing but expose the disappointing
limits of us-based leftist streamer bros
okay so now that we are hopefully on the
same page we are ready to discuss the
threat of russian invasion now russia
has been synonymous for a while with
this information and the internet
censorship and a great way to contract
these is the services of today's sponsor
atlas vpn atlas brings you the best vpn
deal on the market for just 199 per
month with a 30-day money-back guarantee
they offer a high-speed service suitable
both for streaming and gaming moreover
with a single subscription you'll be
able to protect all your devices at the
same time and not only that atlas also
comes with an ad blocker and malware
protection it blocks all the malicious
links ads and trackers and notifies you
when someone is trying to steal your
data it also helps you get the best
deals while shopping online this
includes online subscription services
such as netflix or spotify also airlines
hotels and more right now atlas vpn is
running a huge discount it means you can
get a 3 year subscription for just 199 a
month with a 30 day money back guarantee
time is running out so grab the deal by
clicking the link in the description
below with your subscription you will
also have access to atlas's data breach
monitor feature and here's how that
works inside the app you go to bridge
scanner you type in your email and the
app will let you know whether your
personal information had been leaked
through a past or recent breach so make
sure to take advantage of atlas vpn's
huge discount that's a three-year
subscription for just 199 per month with
a 30-day money-back guarantee link in
the description thank you for checking
out atlas vpn heads like this helps
support what i do and now back to the
program so with all the previous points
in mind it is my hope that we can all
agree that what russia is doing here is
utterly unacceptable both legally and
morally and we haven't even talked about
things like the budapest memorandum a
document russia signed that guarantees
ukraine's territorial sovereignty in
exchange for ukrainians giving up their
nukes so yeah let's not make excuses for
russia kyle
hassan
because there are none let's move on to
the threat of war itself how realistic
is it as you might have guessed there is
no short answer to the question but i'll
try my best to shed light on the matter
the chances for an invasion depend
directly on two things the strength of
ukraine's military and the intensity of
western sanctions i.e how much damage
would russia take militarily and
economically first let's consider the
ukrainian military would they be able to
stop a russian invasion yes and no now
they improved a lot since 2014 and i
really mean a lot when the dawn best war
started back then they had around 3 000
actually deployable troops now they have
between 150 and 200 000 plus a quarter
of a million in reserve some sources
mention 900 000 for a letter but based
on the ukrainian sources i've read the
quarter of a million figures seems to be
the correct one in addition to that
comedy territorial defense forces
totaling at around 130 thousand these
are volunteers trained by donbass
veterans tasked with supportive roles
such as guarding local strategic objects
setting up checkpoints and if necessary
waging insurgency warfare against an
invading force added to the pilots the
national guard is sort of well-armed
military police numbering around 50 000
or so keep in mind that these numbers
might change quickly especially nowadays
though usually upward in any case for
this analysis they will suffice so how
about the russian forces near ukraine
most current estimates put their numbers
at around 130 150 000 so that doesn't
look too bad right looks like the
russians are outnumbered pretty heavily
however the russian military has around
a million active personnel with 2
million in reserve added to this is the
russian national guard with 340 000
personnel so even though the troops on
the border aren't such an overwhelming
force russia has enormous reserves for a
prolonged conflict meaning if a longer
invasion is to come they can keep
rotating fresh troops into ukraine as
the defenders slowly wear out the ratio
is similar in terms of land vehicles but
where russia truly has an edge is their
air force and navy 5.5 000 aircraft
versus 300 and more than 600 ships
versus around 60. now of course the
entire russian army cannot be deployed
in ukraine russia is a huge country and
they need a good part of their personnel
and hardware just to man the borders but
even if half of their army can be
deployed ukraine already has a huge
problem on top of that ukraine is
severely lacking in anti-air defenses
meaning russian planes and helicopters
could make short work of many strategic
targets before a single invading russian
soldier even sets foot in the country so
with all that said would russia be able
to steamroll ukraine in a matter of days
i don't think so in case of an all-out
invasion i assume they would make quick
progress in certain areas and get bogged
down in others or advance only with
significant losses despite being
outnumbered ukrainians have a number of
very useful military hardware on their
hands with almost every nato country
constantly sending them more examples
include shoulder-fired surface-to-air
missiles such as the polish drum or the
well-known stinger and also anti-tank
systems such as the british in-law or
the american javelin so okay ukraine got
some missile launchers what's the big
deal one might ask it actually is a
pretty big deal these weapons are what
we call force multipliers you know it's
nice to have a big inexpensive tank or
helicopter but if one guy can take them
out with one missile that's a rather
disproportionate loss there not to
mention the mere existence of entire
missiles can negate the russian
helicopter threat and force planes to
higher altitudes at which they are far
less effective at bombing targets and
laws and javelins but especially
javelins are ludicrously effective
against soviet armor the letter secret
is that the rocket travels upward after
launch and hits vehicles directly from
above for soviet armor and af wheeze
that's a guaranteed death sentence now
all this might not be enough to deter
putin after all at least for now and
that last part is key here there is a
temporal element to this threat meaning
the longer putin holds up on the
invasion the higher the costs will be
thus the lower the chances of the
invasion actually happening the ideal
time window for an invasion would be
between mid-february and late march when
the ground is frozen solid enabling
heavy vehicles to roll through and i'm
fairly certain that if putin doesn't
invade by late march he will not invade
period but let's say he does let's say
the russian army starts advancing they
engage the defenders they move in from
belarus from the northeast from the
dumbass from crimea and they land in the
south in that case for ukrainians phase
1 of the conflict will be about
inflicting as much damage to russians as
possible even if russians will break
through in the end the more casualties
there are the more putin risks domestic
instability which is approval ratings
aren't too high nowadays hovering at
around 69 percent this might seem like a
lot but in terms of russia this is
rather low in 2014 a 62 approval rating
already prompted him to engage in small
victorious wars abroad such as crimea
add 10 000 coffins to the equation and
he might just start having problems back
home but let's assume russians managed
to break through ukrainian defenses with
only moderate losses the domestic
situation in russia becomes tense but
more or less under control we now enter
phase 2 by russian troops move into the
ukrainian countryside and start
encircling major cities and this is
where the ukrainian defenders can really
shine as we've seen in iraq and
afghanistan insurgency warfare can be
very effective even against a much more
powerful occupying force but in the case
of ukraine this force would be somewhat
weaker and the insurgents would be more
numerous better organized and much
better equipped this would lead to
significant loss of life and equipment
on the russian side consequently
increasing domestic instability and this
would only get worse and worse over time
so it's not unlikely that even after a
somewhat successful offensive the
russians would need to pull out due to
mounting losses of course while all this
is going on sanctions would be in full
swing while the russian economy was made
rather resilient to these sanctions
would still do lots of damage which
again contributes to domestic
instability increasing casualties are
one thing but when people's salaries are
suddenly worth a third less and
everything in the store becomes twice as
expensive that's where the problems
begin usually so yeah as you can see
this game is rather complex we cannot
eliminate the chance of invasion but we
can make damn sure that putin will think
twice before making a move he already
didn't expect such a united and strong
western response to the crisis and if we
keep supplying ukraine with gear while
presenting a united front on the
diplomatic stage we might just be able
to hold putin back until the first
thought sets in so this was my casual
but informed take on the whole russian
invasion threat once again we don't know
what's going to happen i do hope there
won't be war but even if there will be
well there are multiple possibilities i
guess we'll just have to see in any case
the final decision will be made inside
putin's head which is an increasingly
unstable place as time goes on so as i
said i guess we'll just have to wait and
see in the meantime thank you for
watching and don't forget to like and
subscribe and i also have a patreon if
you think this content is worth your
money and i'll be seeing you on the
front line or hopefully not